I reject nation I'm Greg Alba ah so am I
just kidding I'm John we are gonna watch
today patron video requests time you see
on our patreon we do TV show reactions
and Q&A s and today is a patron video
request that comes from a man named
Cameron French this one is another top
10 movie production nightmares see we
didn't talk to any production nightmares
never doing another one
and Cameron French was most interesting
patrons for a while because the longest
time we would never really hear from him
he might chew requests here or there I
would always try to get info on the guy
for months lately we've actually been
messaging each other and I finally get
to know the guy a little bit he's 24
years old he lives somewhere in the
world and he's a big wrestling fan and I
found out he's a big fan of channels
like the schmoes know the Chris Stockman
the Jeremy John's the movie couple our
show of course watch Romania because
he's a wrestling fan and one of his
reward tiers was that he would get a
thank you letter written by us that we
would just write front page back page it
would have been great but he said no
thank you to that because he knows were
pervs that we would stalk him like crazy
so good call on your end Cameron good
call we show up unannounced to
everybody's
anyway let's watch your fun little video
here from a WatchMojo the greatest list
video channel of all time loving
watching mojo mojo baby
these movies got made I mean it's just
you've done fired director and this is
really done some horrible thing welcome
to watchmojo.com and today we're
counting down for another sometimes I
try to make a music Star Wars movie
before we begin have you publish new
videos every day so be sure to subscribe
for more great content for this list
we're considering everything from a
director's penchant for perfectionism
too overbearing studios to inclement
weather as reasons for disastrous
productions
I'm doing doesn't easy we're gonna shoot
and I don't see a title famous for its
mishaps on this list check out our other
list of movie production nightmares
they've got them all there was a
Christmas lights I put about to make
everyone happy
not really my favorite movies of all
time
this classic high school drama / comedy
follows a group of teenagers on their
last hurrah of summer vacation an ambien
however the shenanigans were not limited
to the film itself developed a hitman
and were snags along the way in Charlie
70s fashion one of the members of the
crew was arrested for growing marijuana
to unspecified sources actors Harrison
Ford beau Hopkins and polymath were
allegedly drunk
almost every which would have killed for
Ford getting kicked out of his motel at
another point someone said what
this is already better than lost but not
imagine a king who fights his own
battles
wouldn't that be a son it seems Wolfgang
Petersen's interpretation of Homer's
epic poem angered the gods because it
brave critics as well as its fair share
of hardships while being made you know
it's there waiting in a twist of our
lives
Brad Pitt played the legendary Achilles
actually tore his Achilles tendon
Walther hurricane laid waste to the wall
of Troy set right as they were intending
to shoot scenes in front of it
filmmakers had no choice but to rebuild
the entire thing Wow the guards were
detained for stealing from set claiming
that their paychecks had been halted
after the hurricane and Brad Pitt was
growing marijuana number Bladerunner
dude air support sci-fi movies ever made
this masterpiece was based on philip k
dick novel Do Androids Dream of Electric
Sheep the film went through various
screenplays and directors before Ridley
Scott finally got on board but the
enemies three versions have to say that
neo was quarreling both star Harrison
Ford and Skye and to a rather
contentious relationship during
production but the actor wasn't the only
one with qualms because of how hands-on
stop was he found himself at odds with
the crew who even started a t-shirt war
by donning shirts saying yes governor
my ass wanting to voice their
displeasure with the English directors
approach Wow number 7 the Conqueror
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
after the code stated that everything
was fine the production caramel I began
guest job nice to see your treacherous
head is not safe on your shoulders the
multi cancer including director John
Powell actress Susan Hayward and even
John Wayne himself all died of cancer in
the following years Wow Armand Ari's
committed suicide after being diagnosed
with terminal cancer and actress Agnes
Moorehead reportedly said shortly before
her death that she should have never
taken her role number six fantastic work
a cake what's that for this great movie
thinking he was more than than right I
mean the first s whatever was the last
that's how I'm feeling comes to light it
was doomed from the beginning
director Josh Trank was extremely
promising but several reports started to
come out claiming he bullied kate mara
during filmmaking what are you not going
to be a tool the server's regional
Abbott affected his relationship with
both the studio and his cast and 20th
Century Fox did not like his take on the
producers ended that entirely rewriting
transcending but needed standings for
shooting since the actors were all busy
with other projects Trang tweeted his
displeasure with the release version of
the film and it's thought he hurt his
reputation so much that he lost his job
doing a Star Wars movie as a result
number five Evans game it's too
dangerous to be four distinct
from the director who brought us the
deer hunter came the sprawling Western
taking place in 1890s Wyoming and it
kind of sucked
since Michael Cimino had impressed
everyone with his five oscar-winning
film whoa he was given complete a
stickler for authenticity shamino had
many of his sets destroyed and rebuilt
costing the studio millions of dollars
what's more the production was accused
of Cruelty to Animals Jimmy knows
caramel I've destroyed following this
disastrous development away turning him
into another of Hollywood's many one-hit
wonders
the ordeal also meant that studio
started to exercise more control over
directors way to ruin it for everyone if
we fail the flag of the United States
fails number four alien 3 we give you
thankful Lord
the wrath has come the time was near for
us to be judged after escaping the
Sulaco Ripley crashes on a
maximum-security prison planet but soon
realizes she didn't come alone multiple
directors were attached to this movie
before newcomer David Fincher was
brought on the script had already been
seen multiple rewrites and changes were
still being made during shooting
new venture arrived to a colorful budget
at a cosmic design story involving a
wooden planet populated by monks with no
time to pick up the pieces and execs
breathing down his neck to make the
release date venture ultimately disowned
this installment of the alien quadrilogy
that's a bit uncharitable just a god
like the most signature
[Music]
this tale of supernatural possession is
regarded as one of the most celebrated
horror movies in cinema but it's actors
barely made it out in one piece Stanley
Kubrick was a notoriously difficult
director to work with manatees up to the
script daily and demanding repetitive
takes give me the bag give me the bat
March the seen wearing Wendy backs of
the stairs swinging a baseball bat
reportedly required 127 takes and holds
the Guinness record for the most tapes
of a single scene with dialogue however
members of the contest this statement
saying it was actually around 35 to 45
either way that's not excessive Shelley
Duvall even suffering from hair loss due
to stress number two the revenant this
beautifully shot film chronicles a
frontiersman tale of survival director
Alejandro Inarritu wanted to shoot on
location in Alberta Canada to properly
convey the sheer desperation of the
characters dealing with their
environment however Alberta was hit with
record high temperatures that year
melting most of the snow production was
ultimately to Argentina to complete
filming in a suitable environment
either fire a movie as a result of how
challenging but the actors didn't have
it any easier Leonardo DiCaprio recalled
the challenges he faced including
braving frozen rivers sleeping in dead
animals and risking hypothermia real
dead out of us at least he finally got
his Oscar James Cameron's underwater
sci-fi extravaganza following a deep-sea
drilling crew that stumbles a crane
McWhorter game night anak was in pretty
chaotic waters in order to shoot the
film multiple tanks were made needing a
combined 10 million gallons of water to
fill Wow plastic beads used to cut out
light and simulate the extreme deaths
use beads instead of something laying in
the water because of a safety factor we
had to be able to surface at any moment
if we had a problem especially diving
with actors to achieve Cameron's vision
the production team and actors had to
brave 70 hour work weeks and often
risked their lives since underwater
films were new territory several members
of the cast included Ed Harris and Mary
Elizabeth mastrantonio experienced
emotional breakdowns due to exhaustion
traumatized by the whole ordeal
harrassing High School refused to talk
about the movie for years
right now do you agree with our picks
watch another great clips from watch
mojo and subscribe for new videos every
day
they're talking about those seem like a
walk in the park walkin walk in the park
American Graffiti is one of my all-time
favorite movies I know a lot of people
don't know that that's one of my
all-time favorites and I had no idea
about any of those guys man that's some
funny-ass [ __ ] I'm pretty surprised that
with the kind of behavior
Harrison Ford displayed on set if that
is to be true that he was drunk almost
every night that he would immediately
cast him in Star Wars like you just have
so much of it that I had not cast yes
guy growing marijuana on said that
wouldn't be a problem now it depends we
were shooting but most like happy a
problem we'd be okay with that
no nowadays it's gonna be like I hope
you grew enough for everybody I just
surprised somebody tried to burn down
his hotel room yeah who hates George
Lucas and ecru I don't know man that's a
pretty crazy stuff but hey they turned
out a great movie my favorite ones are
the ones where movies are actually great
and then you find out that there's some
terrible stuff that happened to it that
stuff with Troy they have that opening
line about it seemed like the gods were
against him or some funny [ __ ] like that
right and then you hear what happened
you're like maybe the gods were against
these guys what is that uncanny [ __ ]
where it's like he tore his Achilles
tendon I'm like well that's kilise or
they're about to shoot on this like
giant set then they have to rebuild yeah
we're gonna hurricane whoo it's one of
those weird cases where you're like I'll
hate CGI but then I'll hear about stuff
like this and I'll be like CGI makes so
much sense
so that why you made that choice sure
when you hear of [ __ ] like this
happening that's just so unfortunate man
yeah it's gonna hurt everybody's soul
after that I think I'm in the minority
here
I enjoy the movie Troy Troy like like
quite a bit have you seen the director's
cut because the director's cut is widely
regarded as being like the good movie
version of that of that film I don't
even improvement I don't even enjoy that
movie on a level of it's so bad it's
good or its entertainingly bad yeah I
just I just like that like that movie I
think the fight scenes are really cool
too like that fight that they always
show with Eric Bana and Brad Pitt going
at it I mean Brad Pitt does a terrible
accent Orlando Bloom is very annoying in
the yes besides those factors and no I
have not seen the awesome director's cut
I'd still enjoy the movie so kudos to
them for pulling this bad boy off I got
like Brian Cox like Eric Bana I think
they're really good in the film Blade
Runner I heard on Blade Runner 2049
because Ridley Scott was an active
producer on that film and he was on set
for a lot of that film that even then
him and Harrison Ford were not getting
along with each other
like so many years later they just don't
like one another man they just don't
click but what was the key factor that
stopped you know Ridley from bringing
him right back for the next day I find
that dynamic interesting because Ridley
Scott's a director where often times
we'll see him bring back actors from
previous films which is usually a sign
that they got along forget I mean UK
didn't hear of a case where they don't
get along but they still bring them for
a different movie because they know the
right person to put in that role but
specifically Ridley Scott I mean the
whole crew turning against him I know
this was a very trouble if there's three
cuts of this movie from the same guy
shows you it was probably a trouble
production yeah that's an odd leadership
choice to be like no no no I gotta get
the movie right again yeah I gotta get
it right again again this time is the
right one it's like do you really know
what you're [ __ ]
yeah and he's pretty vocal about it too
about how the crew felt about him how
Harrison felt about him he doesn't shy
away from that but yeah like when him
and Russell Crowe were like best buds I
would when I think of like Russell Crowe
and Harrison Ford I'm like Russell Crowe
be the one who's most likely to be the
hardest one to work with well they were
together on so many projects so Krause
seems like more like like Harrison Ford
seems like he might be a squeaky we open
in a laid-back kind of way whereas like
Russell Crowe seems like he could be
more up-tempo about that yeah you know I
mean he's got that reputation throw him
phones and stuff like I got to imagine
that's more volatile yeah he's but you
were to hear Ridley Scott get a mean he
makes like wanted to move
a year so you rarely hear of him he shot
all the money in the world and like a
day yeah that christopher plummer in
there let's do it
what's this one called the Genghis Khan
one I've not seen it but I like watching
any movies what's the more Charlton
Heston plays in Mexican Oh remember
that's special shopping yeah he's
Mexican he always straight-up Mexican
damn I remember no Sean Connery plays a
Spaniard yeah I like that I like
watching them just because I never can
see past it I just can't
through out how long I'm watching that
movie for I'm trying to come it's John
Wayne yeah whitest guy you know hey man
if Mickey Rooney can do it so can John
Wayne I've heard terrible things about
Josh Trank on this set I heard he was
drunk all the time every evening and he
said George Lucas's hotel room oh yeah
yeah man this is one of those
fascinating ones where I was like I
don't know whose story is right but it
seems like no matter whose story you're
listening to this was an ugly set to be
on I think out of all the movies on this
list this is the one where it's most
present yeah you can just see that
there's a troubled production you know
when you watch this movie
this is totally this so on screen like
if I had never heard it and then I
watched this film I would go something
went wrong something went wrong with the
studio's and Josh Trank clashing or
something nowadays it's easier than ever
when you could feel there's a clash
between creatives and the studio heads
well and now it's so highly publicized
and yeah people like I feel like this
was probably a transitional moment in
that phenomenon because now the barrier
the transparency is that much more thin
but then you also have a certain amount
of like who's just damaged controlling
you know like you look at a Suicide
Squad and David Ayer is pretty
diplomatic about that and you're like
are you just learning from your thanks
or you know I love Joe
shrinks tweet though about how his movie
would have been great I I wonder I mean
he can say that because no will never
ever see it yeah now it's just whatever
you're thinking of just trying to save
his own ass from all these things that's
the thing is is he done now
he'll be back a min/max lioness made
chronicle ya amic do is gonna be back
with a new movie anytime now when people
get a hankering for Chronicle to they
were wanting it it's never gonna happen
Heaven's Gate I've talked about on this
channel before I don't really feel like
covering again alien 3 this is another
movie it is nowhere near on the level of
the first two aliens nowhere near way
above but I don't think it is anywhere
near as terrible as people I've made it
out to be I think there's plenty of cool
things and nifty ideas in here that are
worth exploring and one of the most
favorite shots out of the entire
franchise people always associate this
as the downfall of the Alien franchise
and yeah there's already missing made
there because quality is nowhere near on
par but I think there's some still some
great cinematography in this film you
still get some of those cool visuals
that David Fincher is known to work with
his cinematographer on that famous shot
of just the alien who just like just got
out of the shower
drool because the alien drool doesn't
just come out of their mouth it also
comes like down over there yeah I know
it's everywhere
they're always drooling from everywhere
yeah I mean I really like the see with
what's the robot's name not David
whatever the robots naming it where he's
like she puts him back together in his
head she has a whole scene with it oh is
it Henriksen is it his robot is it his I
can't Jim Hanson that movie overall I
enjoyed it I liked the ending to it as
well have you seen it you know I've seen
disparate clip bits of it but no I
haven't seen alien 3 or 4 oh wow yeah
and see the thing is at least as an
outsider's perspective I kind of view
this is not the downfall of the Alien
franchise but just its failure to
achieve true classic status with a
perfect number three yeah you know we
talked about The Shining so many times
the revenant I feel like is just a
documentary about how hard it was to
make this movie I feel like it's all
there us it is all there on screen but
all those problems work so well for the
movie that's the ironic part about that
film is this stresses that Shelley
Duvall went through for the shining
worked for that movie because of the
performance it gave no one ever should
be pushed that limit but but since we
have men since we have that film with
that performance in those real-life
struggles you have making that movie
that performance is great but everyone
talks about Jack yeah but the revenant
same thing man it's such a physically
demanding role with DiCaprio does their
and like I'm kind of back and forth I I
don't know what people say like he ate a
real Bison liver like did he did he just
eat some kind of you know safe gelatin
everything did he I didn't people say
like he hit in real dead animals I've
read reports to say he didn't really do
that doesn't like that be a little
ridiculous like we kill the horse for
you to really climb into his little
[ __ ] insane to me there's a
slaughterhouse just nearby they're done
with this one they're shipping it out
you might as well say that CGI bear
attack was real yeah I always wondering
hey they can make animal carcasses in an
effects house pretty easily so I
wouldn't be surprised but the remanence
one of those movies where I feel like if
it was an easy production probably
wouldn't have any never near the end of
like the status it achieved the abyss
I've heard I mean Titanic has like
pretty horrible stories I don't remember
the first one of this covered Titanic
I'll be surprised they didn't but
Titanic was a very crazy production and
I think that preceded it abyss yeah I
heard that was a trouble production I
didn't know about had Harris's trauma on
it though I had heard he had like some
kind of breakdown yeah
yeah I didn't know about him like for
fusing to talk about the film daddy-o's
news to me
I mean James Cameron just is he's that
mm-hmm
that's just James Cameron they have a
breakdown for me James Cameron is known
to be a hard guy to work with
but I'll push it he delivers great films
so what do you want what do you want
you won't be comfortable or do you want
to make some art yeah that makes a lot
of freaking money yeah
lucrative create well this is a fun list
guys me some March 21st 2017 you could
honestly do one of these every six to
eight months and you'd have more movies
I mean World War Z was an honorable
mention like movie put on your next list
gosh Justice League can easily be on
their solos our war story there's so
many like it's so reported now that
these lists will be even easier for you
to put together in the future
yep anyway guys you guys can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification bail checks on patreon TV
show reactions Q&A is John does music
video coverage and thanks again Cameron
French for the recommendation buddy bye